il ya quelqu'un yannick
oh ça partout jacky la bahia moi et moi
et moi j'avoue j'ai dit deux fois moi je
m'y attendais comment vous êtes entré au
str simple je me suis téléporter à tuer
un vampire donc je peux me téléporter
je vous jure on est passé par la fenêtre
non pour ce coup là se téléporte pas un
robin gibb en longueur ou non plus ça
c'était les portes comme ça je sais
c'est de la merde être un loup garou a
parce que tu es un loup garou toi ouais
enfin ça fait cinq jours donc pour le
moment par gratté l'oreille avec le pied
je sers pas grand chose
justement pour nos oreilles bon trêve de
bavardage un laisser faire le
professionnel on and on entendait garder
c'est ma victime jetaient leur premier
enfant réfléchissez deux secondes je
vais pas me nourrir d'un cadavre
1 le sang des morts absolument aucun
goût et je suis un fervent j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] de ça j'étais là en premier en
plus je vais pâturer cadavres c'est
encore plus con premièrement je ne suis
pas nécessairement je me délecte du sang
de la victime est deuxième et
deuxièmement il est hors de question que
je tue ma victime avec un pur ou offert
le plus en bois ça n'a jamais marché
c'est une erreur si ça marche
bon toujours est il que c'est moi le
doyen ici bouge
tu as quel âge j'aurais 516 en mars et
chemise avec des potes
oh
edit quoi bon j'avoue moi j'ai les crocs
non non non c'est pas un jeu de mots
donc soit vous vous décidez maintenant
soit j'y vais je la bouffe et je vous
préviens je vous laisse maintenant doit
pm oui enfin tu vas quand même de garder
un petit neveu s'arranger pour que
métamorphose nu pour botter des culs et
distribue des bonbons j'ai cru bon
yannick qu'est ce que c'est ça hein
qu'est ce que c'est ça hein tu mens pas
ni aller au panier